hey my name is Leticia if you want to  see tips and tricks on how to achieve  the perfect highlight carry on watching  I'm going to start by using the laura  geller do dreamer illuminating drops and  i'll place the products on all the high  points of my face using my fingers to  catch the lights and create a healthy  natural glow don't forget to bring the  illuminator up and around your temples  as this also catches the light lastly  make sure it's all blended and there are  no harsh lines now to intensify the  highlights I'll be using that amrezy  Anastacio Beverly Hills highlighter with  a fan brush all over the same high  points of my face  top tip to create a fuller lip look  using your index finger press it into  the highlighter then onto the center of  your lips use as much as you want until  you find your desired fuller lip look  [Music]  for more videos like this subscribe to  glamour UK's YouTube channel